figure out what the storyline was do you
think it's supposed to be kind of
circusy in a way it is it's a little bit
so it's not just me no it's definitely
um you know I think it's a it's a kind
of screenshot into Wes's brain now you
know I think it's very much a
culmination of his career where he's at
in his life
um you know it was something that we
came out of the quarantine time as well
so you see some of that reflected in the
film it is it's sort of a existential
film I would say
um you have fun doing it I loved doing
it and when you talk about all the
incredible talent in it you know we
really worked in this bubble which is
how Wes likes to work anyway and so we
all stayed in this
um in this kind of in together and the
whole place was locked down so you know
at any moment you'd see like Willem
Dafoe at the cappuccino maker running on
the treadmill and Jeff Goldblum be on
the StairMaster